have you and your kids been to wally
wombats yet
this is such a special play place and it
includes physical and speech therapy for
kids
on top of so much fun
wombats is all about a fun place for
kids and families to really come and
enjoy themselves
the fact that we also offer therapy
along with the kids indoor playground is
really
our unique selling feature
[Music]
speech therapy is really i would say
more common than what a lot of people
realize
often if they come from bilingual
families it can cause a delay in speech
while they're really working out the
differences of the two languages
and then often they'll have problems
basically
developing their their sounds for the
different continents based again on the
difference of the two different
languages so speech therapy is really
it's a popular therapy and we have a
number of speech therapists who work
with kids from all different ages
my name is eric i'm a physical therapist
here at walleye wombats also known as
spot for tots
and it's a great place for children to
come to get physical therapy we have
you know awesome playgrounds and plenty
of tools for
children to incorporate their therapy
into a more playful setting
all right coming up and then step into
the next leg out
same thing try to aim the knee a little
bit more out kids that are active it's
very common that they sprain their ankle
hurt their back
i hurt their knee and then to get them
back to their prior level physical
therapy can can definitely help there
and prevent any you know long lasting
movement difficulties or faulty movement
patterns because of the injury
i want you to hop as much as you can so
the biggest jump is you can do
land without falling and let's do five
times each leg
typical day we have you know i'd say at
least 10 kids and
these kids can be from from newborns all
the way to 18 years old and
so if it's an evaluation they come in we
assess
you know what the issue is and give them
a treatment plan
and a lot of times that includes
exercises here
we do manual therapy techniques here as
well and then we really try to educate
the parents and the children on what
they can do at home to
help improve their their condition it's
a very rewarding experience to watch
kids as they develop
through their milestones and i've had
several kids i started four six months
right and then now they're
a year old almost and they've made
dramatic differences and
they've improved quite a bit and that it
feels really good because everything you
do here you know echoes
for the rest of their life so whatever
improvements they make here
they'll see dividends later as they get
older well often
when you have like a big family you may
have three or four kids
and then one of the kids is in therapy
often the other kids have to come to
therapy but it's a
torture that they have to sit around and
wait for all the
the other sibling to actually finish
their therapy so at wally wombats we
offer the playground
they get a special rate for the family
members while they're attending
and they can go into the playground
playing in the playground and then when
the other child is finished therapy then
they can join them
give wally wombats a call at
702-463-6555 or visit
wallywombats.com